[Música]
soy hijo de una apasionada agente de
viajes y un apasionado meteorólogo
y como no podía ser de otra manera y
siguiendo la tradición familiar salí
animador
si ustedes me deben estar imaginando con
una nariz haciendo así en un bailando
carioca en una fiesta no no no
animador de dibujos animados no 3 de
dibujo animado
y mucha gente no sabe qué animación
viene de ánima que significa alma
espíritu vida
o sea que el animador no es el que mueve
personajitos de un lado para el otro y
nada más sino es alguien que les da vida
hay que darles alma
mama
se recibió de maestra jardinera nunca
ejerció porque por ahí escucho una
vocecita que le dijo
mira vos vas a encargarte de que la
gente viaje sin preocupaciones de
elegirle es un destino que armar
itinerarios y lograr que la gente que
quiere conocer el mundo y tiene ganas de
viajar viajes se hizo agente de viajes a
ella le debo mi amor por los cuentos
por los idiomas y por los viajes
obviamente
mi papá fue un visionario
lo admiro mucho
mi papá
no se quiso quedar como meteorólogo en
el servicio metereológico anotando datos
y armando mapas y todo eso y se imaginó
haciendo un micro televisivo donde iba a
predecir el tiempo en aquella época eso
era visto como si él iba a aparecer como
si fuera aparecer con un búho en el
hombro y con un bonete y un coso negro
así
y lo hizo fue un pionero de la
televisión lo hizo durante cuarenta años
después digo que fue un visionario
porque él se imaginó en el año 94 cuando
internet era pedal se imaginó una página
de servicios meteorológicos pero como
está funcionando hoy y yo lo sé porque
yo estuve ahí yo estaba ahí cuando él me
hablaba de formato y de cosas totalmente
para mirar chino básico
y sin embargo ahí están funcionando
my papá de alguna manera y en algún
momento de su vida se salieron un
poquito del molde y eso a mí me marcó
muchísimo y no es que yo no tenga los
moldes al contrario tengo muchísimos
moldes de hecho
cuando era muy chico quería ser
astronauta
dibujaba astronauta y dibujaba cohetes y
dibujaba alienígenas
después quise ser paleontólogo y dibujar
dinosaurios y dibujar dinosaurios
después quieres y no mucho pero cree así
en la secundaria ya las aspiraciones
eran un poquito más terrenales y ccoo
que tiene con la ingeniería electrónica
y con la ingeniería aeronáutica dibujaba
el circuito dibujar robots dibujaba
aviones y helicópteros y educada
dinosaurios y naves espaciales
me di cuenta un año antes de terminar la
secundaria
que no quería pasarme el resto de mi
vida haciendo cálculos armando o
dibujando planos o trabajando en un
taller entonces ahí vino una crisis de
la cual recuerdo dos cosas una que me
lleve todo
y la otra es que no visite más
peluquerías
así todo me recibí y terminé la
secundaria con el título de técnico
mecánico en máquinas herramientas
tornero
bueno y ahí me fui a ver qué va a ser de
mi vida tengo que trabajar y luego tengo
que estudiar algo de lo cual poder
trabajar entonces según el molde citó
que venía me fui a estudiar yo ya sabía
que quería estudiar artes así que me fui
para el lado de las artes pero las artes
aplicadas aplicadas a que aplicadas a
ganar plata me apoyaban
entonces fui a estudiar
el antepasado del diseño gráfico se
llamaba dibujo publicitario y fui
estudiar eso porque tengo muchas otras
cosas más que nunca terminé algunas y
otra no
recuerdo
que en ese entonces también empecé a
llevar mates en un estudio de televisión
y ahí inesperadamente me llegó la
primera gran lección
un gran amigo y maestro me sentó frente
a un photoshop también antediluviano me
mostró la pantalla
el curso duro creo que dos minutos y
medio tres me sentó en otra pantalla en
otro las herramientas de fotos me dijo
mira esta lupa grande la chica esto hace
así esto hace así esto hace así esto
hace así esto así es esto así esto así
me miró y me dijo dale jugar
yo había dibujado toda la vida y tenía
ahí una máquina que con la que se podía
dibujar también así que es que dice fui
y jugué con toda la pasión que pude le
puse toda la garra a jugar con eso
todo juego tiene sus reglas y esto
también tenía sus reglas y esa regla me
llegó como la segunda elección y la
segunda elección fue horas sillas con
otras palabras pero ahora sillas
que eran una silla y fácil uno no puede
aprender de la noche a la mañana alguna
herramienta o algo así para aprender
algún software es aplicable a muchas
cosas en la vida se necesitaba sentarse
y hacer sentarse y hacer horas silla
aplicable a muchísimas cosas salvo quizá
algunos deportes
así que me senté y jugué con esas reglas
y jugué y jugué mucho y aprendí un
montón de cosas hice infinidad de
comerciales trabajé en vídeos animados y
se muestras de arte de arte digital
después quise transmitir todo esto que
había aprendido hacía los tumbos en un
montón de años y entonces me di cuenta
que me faltaba algo
tenía que organizar todo ese
conocimiento para poder llegar de la
mejor manera posible a los futuros
alumnos
ahora sí allá otra vez ahora sí allá
así que bien me dediqué a jugar aprender
jugar y aprender y siempre así y fueron
llegando muchas lecciones me di cuenta
así de golpe que todo eso que hacía que
me hacía feliz que tenía este que era
apasionado por hacer lo estaba haciendo
y más aún a eso lo habría transformado
en mi carrera
bueno así que siguieron llegando y
siguen llegando más lecciones tres de
las cuales yo digo que son mi posgrado y
son mis tres hijos
digo esto porque ellos
ponen en jaque todos esos moldes todo el
tiempo porque enseñan todo el tiempo
aparte de aprender obviamente enseñan
juegan con esos moldes los rompen hacen
otros y no solo con los de ellos sino
con los míos también tal es así que
cuando la más grande la primera quiso ir
a la escuela tenía que ir a la escuela
no encontrábamos ninguna que nos
convenciera entonces junto a mi mujer y
un grupo de padres también que les
gustaban romper los moldes armamos una
comunidad educativa levantamos una
escuela con pedagogía alternativa y los
mandamos ahí a los chicos
obviamente no podíamos esperar que se
oficializará porque ya sabemos los
tiempos de la burocracia rara vez se
coinciden con los tiempos del ser humano
y los chicos crecen así que bueno
ay pues hoy ya terminó la segunda
primaria la más grande y me dijo papá
quiero ir a estudiar a una escuela
normal
ay está estudiando en la escuela donde
yo me recibí de técnico mecánico airline
como le gusta jugar con los moldes a
esta chica también no
en fin a mí me cuesta muchísimo no
apasionarme por algo si a ustedes no les
pasó o no se apasionaron con algo quizás
porque todavía no lo encontraron
o sea los invito a mirar para adentro y
seguir buscando porque seguramente algo
los va a pasión hay tantas cosas
filosofía historia arte matemáticas
windsurf escalar montañas me encanta
cantar bailar trepar a los árboles
remontar barriletes saltar en bungee ya
volar
y hay muchísimas formas de volar hay
muchas formas de volar pero para mí una
de las más lindas es apasionarse con lo
que uno hace
porque eso nos hace más libres eso nos
da otra mirada nos eleva
nos hace auténticos y nos eleva como
para poder mirar desde arriba los
caminos que podemos seguir o mejor aún
nos hace romper algunos moldes para
inventar caminos nuevos
ya les había contado los moldes
a veces
nos hacen malas pasadas a veces suena el
despertador me despierto voy a trabajar
de salud no voy a trabajar 68 horas a
veces como a veces no vuelvo a casa ceno
así pongo el despertador para mañana
lunes martes miércoles jueves viernes y
tu cuerpo lo sabe sábado hay que salir
porque hay que salir domingo de
depresión porque viene el lunes otra vez
a veces los moldes no juegan esa pasada
yo ya les había dicho que animación
significa viene de al imán y qué
significa alma espíritu vida
yo
los invito
a que no seamos solamente personajitos
que se mueven de acá para allá
hay que animarse
[Aplausos]